If a ship was to capsize,
they don't just turn turtle quickly.
They fill up with water.
And for the vessel to turn
that quickly so that people
would have to hang on to
things, not believable.
Hi, I'm Capt. Wendy Williams.
Recently, I was the first Canadian woman
to captain a mega cruise ship.
Today, we'll be looking
at cruise ship disasters
in movies and TV and deciding
how realistic they are.
It's going to hit!
Jack: Get back!
The Titanic disaster is the one
that everybody associates
with marine disasters.
First of all, it struck an iceberg.
I'm hoping it would never happen again,
but I don't, I never say
it will never happen again.
We just have a lot more technology
and we have associations
and the ability to track some
of the bigger icebergs now.
I don't think that the crew of the Titanic
were even expecting ice.
Whereas now, it's part of the training.
They're closing the doors!
With any incidents on board,
there's checklists of things,
but there are initial actions
for something that may
involve striking or grounding
or hitting another vessel.
And that is to close all
the watertight doors.
What they called watertight compartments
were not actually watertight,
so they actually put doors through
what should've been
watertight compartments.
And what happened was that the
vessel progressively flooded.
If a ship were to have a strike,
there may be the need to be
in a water-filled or water-filling area
and have to do exactly
what Jack and Rose did.
Unfortunately, they got
to the top of the stairs
and things were locked.
That doesn't happen.
There are emergency escapes
that everybody is trained for.
You have to hold an emergency drill.
Jack: I've got you. I won't let go.
Is it advisable to go up or down?
I mean, the ship is sinking.
You're going to do what
you're going to do.
The fight-or-flight kicks in,
and we would be just grappling
to find the highest point
before succumbing to
having to be in the water.
Some people actually
in a situation where the
ship is not actually sinking,
they choose that jumping into the water
is the safest method.
My view and what I tell everybody
and when we're going through training is
your ship is your biggest lifeboat.
You don't want to be in
one of those little boats
unless you absolutely have to.
In this case, a lot of people died
because they could not
safely get off the vessel.
I think it's an eight.
It was really well done,
and I would imagine
that it was very similar to that event.
I've seen the movie. That's food illness.
I've never been on a ship
where there's been an issue with food.
The food and the food preparation,
it's very highly regulated.
Everybody has to have special
food-preparation courses.
I'm sure it does happen, it
just isn't cause for alarm.
Cruise ships have been in the news a lot
for something called norovirus.
Typically, the cruise ship
does not have norovirus on it.
People bring norovirus to the ship.
There's a guy bringing out an AED
that just happens to have one.
Crew members would, even
though they're trained,
they would just be making
people comfortable.
They wouldn't actually be
doing solo medical procedures.
On a vessel of that size,
there would be a dedicated medical crew.
Typically, they would
carry a doctor and a nurse
and have some sort of triage place.
Hand grenade.
Piracy is a thing.
There are pirate attacks
of many different types
of vessels in the world.
Cruise ships are not exempt from that.
I mean, there's all
different shapes and sizes
of how vessels do navigate through areas
where there is a risk of piracy.
There are agencies
that actually put people
on board with weapons.
There's barbed wire on
deck, charged fire hoses.
It can get pretty nasty.
The pirates themselves,
some of them are equipped with
things like rocket launchers
and really bad weaponry
that can do a lot of damage.
I'm assuming the explosion at
the stern of the vessel here
happened because of one grenade.
I don't think a grenade
would be able to take down
a vessel of that size, one of them.
Believability here,
probably four, five,
for how the situations were being handled
and the actual attack itself.
Laser imaging generating
a negative white-screen response, sir.
That's impossible.
Radios, there are so many backups,
and if the radios didn't work,
you have satellite phones,
all sorts of different types
of satellite communication.
To be able to scramble
a ship like that, no.
What's happening here, gentlemen?
There's a lot of people on the bridge.
I'm not sure what they're all doing.
Most cruise companies,
not saying all of them,
they have different terminology,
but we would have what's called
green, yellow, and red conditions.
Green would be when
everything is smooth sailing.
Typically you would have a
navigation officer up there,
you would have an assistant
or a co-navigator,
and you would have one or two lookouts.
That would be the bridge composition.
Our bridges, like, a full red condition,
would be captain, staff captain,
chief mate or communicator, two lookouts.
That's it. Five.
Five of you on the bridge,
handling the situation.
Probably just a pod of whales.
Moving at 31 knots, sir? I don't think so.
Where's it coming from?
Directly beneath us.
This particular cruise ship
is equipped with sonar,
which, I don't know
why you would even need
that. You wouldn't.
So, everything is scrambled
except for the sonar
that's picking up some,
I guess it's a sea monster in this one.
Even though in this particular movie clip,
they're dealing with a sea monster,
not to put whales or large
mammals into a category
of being sea monsters,
very unfortunately,
there are whale strikes.
Cruise ships pay a lot of attention to
give a large leave distance
and to avoid whales at all costs.
Believability from that
bridge scene, probably zero.
This one looked like
Niagara Falls on its side.
Not a believable wave.
A tsunami is biggest when
it kind of hits the shore.
Out at sea, a tsunami might just be
a wave like any other wave.
So the fact that this is a
tsunami and not a rogue wave,
yeah, probably not that believable.
Being that a tsunami wave
wouldn't look like that,
you wouldn't necessarily navigate
away from the actual wave,
but you would navigate away
from the area of concern if you could.
I do remember seeing this as a kid,
and I remember the dining-room scene
and everything going upside down.
Are tables and chairs and
pianos and things secured?
Cruise ships, larger vessels,
they have something called a heavy weather
or a heavy object register list.
And yes, larger, big-ticket items
that can cause a lot of
damage, like a piano,
could literally go through
a wall, a bulkhead.
So they are secured.
Tables and chairs, no,
they would be moveable.
And for the vessel to turn that quickly
so that people would
have to hang onto things;
not believable.
If a ship was to capsize,
they don't just turn turtle quickly.
They fill up with water.
All right, now what?
We're in shaft alley. Nowhere
is the steel hull thinner.
This hull is only 1 inch thick.
Would there be a sustained amount of time
that people could have
survived inside there?
I mean, possibly yes.
There would be air pockets.
The likelihood of there
being that much air,
that much time, highly unlikely.
The shaft alley, that's interesting,
because the shell-plating
thickness is "only 1 inch."
That is probably icebreaker class.
One inch would be exceptionally thick.
Ship hulls are not that thick typically,
but in engine spaces, technical
spaces, they would be.
Thickness varies depending
on how the ship is built
and for what class.
I'd probably give it a nine
as far as fun movies go;
believability, two, three.
The deadly Pandora virus
is spreading rapidly.
Unprecedented threat requires
a worldwide quarantine.
A virus?!
Stop the ship!
Given that it was created in 2012 --
the pandemic took everyone by surprise,
and certainly cruise ships
that were already in mid-cruise
suddenly were getting cases
of the virus on board.
The Diamond Princess was very unfortunate
that she had a lot of cases on board
and then was put under quarantine.
She was kind of the worst-case scenario.
Ships are now being
constructed with ventilation
such that it's independent in cabins,
filtration systems, much like
the airline industry did.
Announcer: As we greet a
sunny day 12 after virus!
Today's delicious buffet
features fresh seagull and
hull-scraped barnacles.
Would the ship look like
that after 12 days? No.
But in "The Simpsons," where
all that's absolutely perfect.
Vessels could only be
out at sea for as long
as their fuel and food supply
would allow them to be.
We didn't and we wouldn't
keep people past that point.
Cruise ships do carry a lot of food,
and they carry food in excess
of what the voyage length would be,
but not by that much.
So I'd probably give that a nine,
just because it's actually pretty spot-on
for having been made almost
a decade before our pandemic.
No, don't let him drink that!
Don't let him drink our torpedo juice.
They're in a ship's jail, or a brig.
Ours look a lot different than that.
You wouldn't be thrown
in there with others.
There are holding cells,
and they are typically a
cabin without furniture,
with a mattress on the ground,
and they're under camera surveillance
and they have a window, a
non-break window, in a door.
Typically, they're not
in there for very long.
It could be just the night
before we get to port.
But there's a lot of factors
before we could actually put
somebody in a kind of time-out.
Whatever the situation
is, it's to mitigate
anybody else getting
hurt from their actions
or from them harming themselves.
This is a big cruise ship!
It's got, like, a big, deep sound.
It's like a [imitating engine starting].
Yeah, if you're starting the engine.
But we would be hearing a steady
"guh, guh, guh, guh, guh."
The guy that was doing the kind of low
"boom, boom, boom" is probably closest.
It depends what kind of
propulsion they have.
So if they have big
diesel engines working,
you may have that guy that was generating
that "boom, boom, boom, boom" sound.
It's almost a comforting
sound. I find it comforting.
[alarm going off]
You wouldn't be left alone,
so that was a little unrealistic.
Kind of a common thread here,
everything on a cruise ship
is done with checklists
so that we don't forget people,
we don't forget to sweep areas.
It would be part of the
security team's protocol
to escort them to a muster area.
That would not happen.
Believability of the jail
scene, not believable.
This is dealing with the rogue wave.
For a long time, people
didn't even believe
that rogue waves actually existed.
It's an anomaly wave
that is different from
all of the other waves
in a certain sea state.
And then it could overturn
vessels or come at vessels.
I got it! I got it!
Come on.
Turn.
Basically, the tip, or the bow,
has what's called a collision bulkhead,
and it's very strong construction.
You never really want to
take anything broadside,
because even in a small sea,
a vessel can get into
what's called synchronous,
a synchronicity,
which will cause it to
become very unstable.
The announcements were not appropriate.
I felt that they caused
panic. And as a captain,
you want everybody to
know what's happening,
but there are ways to word
things to make people feel
like their understanding of the situation,
this is what's happening,
but I am in the hands
of a very trained crew,
and if I follow
instruction, I will be safe.
You would have crew members
whose duty it would be
to do crowd control.
Cruise ships have a fantastic
stability criteria, they call it,
and it would take a h--- of a
lot to capsize one of these.
Is it going to happen as a result of the
general rogue waves that
I've read about? Not really.
Now, if a cruise ship
were to go off vertical,
these areas that are not
watertight would fill with water,
causing the capsize.
A good example of that we may have seen
that maybe people will understand
is the Costa Concordia.
She went over, and she
would've kept going over
were it not for the depth
of water that she was in.
That's a little bit of a movie thing.
You're not going to really get explosions,
because explosions would have to do
with vapors catching
fire somehow or igniting
and a large amount of vapors
in an area causing
these random explosions.
And on cruise ships,
you just don't have that
in the accommodation.
I can't think of something that
would cause those fireballs.
Although exciting, very exciting.
Believability of what was going on,
probably a five, four,
somewhere in that realm.
But fun. Fun to watch.
Ready.
Now.
For somebody to be able to control
the main engines of a vessel, no,
they're not hooked in
to an automation system
that anybody would be able to take over.
There's automated systems on board,
but everything can be done manually.
What are these switches here?
Don't you touch them!
They open the ballast doors.
You want to flood the ship?
There aren't ballast doors.
There's watertight doors
and there's ballast tanks.
Those are the tanks that
you can fill with water
to change the trim of a vessel.
Someone's just taken the wrong term
and put it with the wrong equipment.
It'd have to have been going
at a very, very fast rate
for it to sort of glance off like that,
but the amount of speed,
and the two vessels would've
been fairly crumpled.
There was a few black
marks along the side,
not even a crumpled bow.
Yeah, not really believable.
For the cargo vessel to have
an anchor just swinging loose,
that wouldn't happen.
Anchors are either stowed
or they're deployed.
The cargo vessel was not moving,
and there was no sea to
make the anchor swing.
Those things weigh tons and tons.
Believability on a scale
to 10, maybe three, two.
Not a lot there, meat on the
bones, for an actual incident.
My favorite cruise ship scene from today
would have to be "Titanic."
It's the basis for
all the safety protocol that we do today,
and I think the portrayal
of what was happening,
the severity of the situation,
was very readily understood.
If you have enjoyed this today,
all you have to do is click the link above
and set sail for another one.